walk him to this video part 17th of the
pre-war championship match series and
it's time to go back yeah long long way
back in time but the circumstances of
this game just too too nice to not show
it
it's a came from 1987 when almond was
basically an unknown junior player and
he entered to the World Junior
Championship played in the Philippines
in 1987 and the and he wanted he was not
particularly favored to win it there
were many strong juniors around
especially from the back then Soviet
Union but at the anti emerge to win this
title and this was basically his
breakthrough and he became known to the
chess world really before that he was
really not known player yeah and I'm
just going to show a game that is funny
and some some aspects he's playing this
game seemed darkest on the Norwegian now
Grandmaster and you note Norwegian
pakistan's also the former coach of
Magnus cousin him he worked with him for
some years and Mark misses you know
years and so Alan played Mario strainer
in 1987 even before Magnus was born so
on it's a quite funny thing to look at
this this big age difference between the
two two players yeah back then Augustine
at Christine himself was the junior
player of course it's about juniors and
an additional fun aspect of this game is
let's have a look
plays knight c6 on the first move quite
funny but usually after 90 of three we
just transposed to a regular opening
um I also recommend why provide players
just to play 9003 it's really not much
used to look at those kind of lines or
even e5 after 93 like usually we'll play
e5 anyway and we get ROI here like many
of the like many games in the series by
5 Ashiya I've ruined no pesum openings
alright but let's see an additional
funny thing is that artists tinea goes
for that this rare line in the in the
way and this is called the Norwegian
defence so lots of Norway in this video
and therefore you are fitting nicely
into the spirit of this serious to what
you have tied for the upcoming match
yeah this line is called the new vision
line and this is also due to the efforts
of the black player here in this game he
played this quite a number of times and
to be honest I think it's just a bad
line and I'm not quite sure how he
managed to play so many games with it
and and even wind quite a number of them
may be the surprise value yet the
problem of this line is it loses lots of
time black gets this important Bishop
but it's simply a very slow line yeah
white cannot really take him it doesn't
promise much because black can take here
and this way sets to regain the pawn
white has gained nothing here the best
line is just castles and now black plays
d6 sv v pawn was hanging now and white
sets to open up the position this is
very logical Black has lost time with
his Knight so white should open up the
position to make use of them
engine development yeah black took on b3
this is certainly the right decision
this is a good piece and you need to get
rid of it so we took and here black has
a choice
it seems that nowadays while this line
is very rare when it is played people
usually go for the capture which is
probably not so logical in itself after
having lost quite some time opening up
the position but it seems that after the
move that artists and played he played
f6 I know it looks ugly but if I was
hanging and you you had to take or play
of six there's not much else yeah I
think I prefer that so if 6 is yeah
covering this pawn but still not helping
at all with the developing pieces and
black suffers from a lack of
coordination the whole game yeah Bushido
played 93 which just takes the pawn and
yeah black responds but Bishop is
haven't quite logical still the bishop
won't be 7 yeah it puts some pressure on
d4 pawn but it's not helping to defend
the light squares and this is
immediately addressed by Knight age 4
intending Queen h5 check if the bishop
would be on e6 for instance you always
would have Bishop f7 to interpose but
now yeah this is of course not possible
yeah black needs to do something here
against us he played Knight to e7 to
make sure that after the check which is
not played g6 is possible yeah on I
played them in a very logical way I
think he took on e5 problem is how do
you continue to yeah to increase your
rear pressure he intends to play Queen
f3 1 still support night at 5 for
example
and yeah well as long as this
possibilities in the position you cannot
go Queenie a three so we just take on
only five and follows up with Queen of
three in this position black could have
considered to take with the F pawn it's
not it's not as bad as it looks maybe at
first I thought okay maybe have four
just opening up the position but black
can maybe even play like that and then
castle um yeah it's it's it looks shaky
but okay this extended fianchetto yeah
the bishop on b7 is protecting blacks
King so it's maybe not that bad that one
white is better but maybe it's still a
playable game white of course does not
necessarily need to play a four
immediately after this he could also
think about the move like Bishop g5 for
example not sure f takes d5 was a
possible as you he took with the
deep-ando and now we see that white
gains lots of time played Queen f3 and
we see that rock d1 and an upcoming move
which comes with tempo and the black has
a hard time to get his pieces developed
if he plays Knight to g6 there's Queen
age five and it's an immediate immediate
loss I cannot go to g6 this is hanging
but how do you get your pieces untangled
he played them
twin to d7 here intending whoops that
antenna Queen e6 and after.look D 126
exactly that was put on the board yeah
obviously I'm white has a good position
this is easy to see but how do you
continue here how do you make any
substantial progress yeah you could
think about nine and five but the
problem is like just takes and he takes
F it's not possible so this doesn't
really help this is quite okay on edge
for this piece because it simply
prevents the Black Knight from moving
the Black Knight would move this is
always not f5 like that for example if
white would let's say zero then you
always have this idea so this isn't bad
at all on edge form and yeah how do you
progress the thing is I think what
really should play exactly the move is
playing now he plays 925 now think you
really should do that as long as you got
the chance if white plays some yeah
white can play a slow move let's say
before up it should be three what I'm
getting at is that maybe black can think
about preventing 95 when you move like
c6 but it also looks really ugly just
have a look at that yeah it's very ugly
yeah but White has the chance to play 95
in this exact moment and I think I
really should take this chance it's a
it's a good piece on d5 and blackness
basically needs to take it at one point
or another you cannot tolerate this
piece there you could theoretically
speaking try to play something like that
and here try to just keep them piece on
d5 but this is incredibly hard form for
a human player to do tolerating such a
piece the computer is not so impressed
with White's position it tests why it's
better but not winning
and I guess black still has a fairly
resilient position it's not fantastic
why do you think but it doesn't seem to
be an instant loss for for black so
maybe this is what what he should have
done he decided to capture on d5 which
is the far more human with you want to
get rid of this piece but now after he
takes d5 Queen f7 and c4 we see that
this pawn capture on d5 introduces a new
yeah a new point of this position this
possible central breakthrough creating a
person at the center and also note that
these spots
d5 is protected last diversity for
really limit the scope of this
celebration only seven so white keeps
them very nice and also easy to handle
advantage in this position this is why
black probably should have gone for this
long castles idea simply because it's
the farmer qiyam type of type of
position okay
played Bishop e7 preparing castles but
the problem is you don't really get that
far nine and five yeah and now we can we
can check what happens if black castles
this is the problem very cute move and
the motif to remember with the knight on
f5 this Bishop h6 move can be deadly if
this is an opinion this is of course the
point winning the Queen and black
iridium has no way to prevent material
losses here what we'll just take him on
let's say this one is another way to
lose substantial material
so black cannot castle and yeah what did
you do he played Luke the aide and
you're really running out of moves a bit
so not nice at all
but this game is also instructive to
show how to convert such a position that
is not rushing things
his first completing is development
Bishop III simple and strong and now g6
is played Knight to h6
this is also a move or motif to take
note of this Knight looks at first like
being a bit offside
it's on the edge of the board but as I
showed you with this with this arrow it
controls g8 which means that oops I
didn't want to do that it controls g8 so
black cannot castle and this is of
course very important this King is stuck
on on yet it also cannot play King f7 of
course the night is just far too
annoying on h6 okay at first you need to
need to play here not nothing else yeah
and here's an instructive point here
I played the move Queen to d3 if you
give that to a to an engine to a
computer it will point out Queen g3 as
as a big mistake because he takes b5 it
considers to be directly winning I'm
pretty sure that Anand has had
calculated this but what if what I
believe is he saw this in m5 takes only
six the problem is I should show that if
black recaptures then Luke a seven is
just deadly very very sorry piece
something like that
56 coming Black is completely busted
this is very easy to see but I guess the
point is another one he probably saw
something like that
f5 takes me eight and now White has one
two points which is nice but he also has
destroyed his structure which was very
um yeah very nicely protected and
keeping the position together and it
seems that black has chances to get the
d5 pawn back think of a four and taking
on d5 the computer is just completely
unimpressed and since why do white is
winning which is probably true but it's
a bit more difficult for a human to play
there's also ideas like f4 where you are
having this piece caught off on h6 it
feels like White has lost coordination a
bit and he therefore played the human
move Queen g3 and it's it's it's simple
and strong the ideas of black now plays
g5 there's not and this f5 you can
simply take it it's a nice technical
idea and this means that also this move
is a tactical possibility furthermore it
intends h4 and h5 and we see an
additional point of h4 just in the next
move Bishop c8 first was plate covering
f5 now he played edge form and one
important point of this whole setup with
Queen g3 and h4 s if black now plays f5
White has a very simple positional move
Bishop g5 and this is just very nice
it's this this kind of configuration is
nice this Bishop is always protecting
the night if takes poops and not that
you just we capture and keep this this
night on h6 controlling those vital
squares and the disposition for instance
black will simply explode on e5
it's no way to defend to the center here
so a very nice positional way to wrap a
black of all kinds of counterplay yes he
could have maybe you want quicker with
the concrete plate but this just this
just kills our counter plane makes it
easier to to convert ya know Bishop d6
was played and Queen f3 back this idea
is prevented now of course and you can
use the Queen more effectively on f3m
there should be seven back thus there
was also simply sea fire threatened so
hard to do anything else and now looks
he won in this position again White had
a tactical idea he could have played two
hoops in d6
which is quite strong look at this check
check
this is completely deadly no way would
like to defend this but it's it's also
besides some being being deadly it is
also not necessary you can simply win
with good positional moves
Roxy wanna just preparing this and black
has no counter play whatsoever so this
is just just simple and strong I'm not
sure maybe even saw d6 and calculated
some lines then decided okay let's just
try to win without any complicated
calculation also you need to note at the
time Ireland was just 18 years old and
back then he was known for his
exceptionally quick play he rarely used
more than 30 or 40 minutes per game even
in tournament chess where he could have
thought two or three hours he was just
spending 30 minutes or 40 minutes even
against top top
grandmasters over the years he slowed
down a bit he still can play quickly if
he wants to tournament chess but usually
he takes his time like everyone else he
really gets into yeah really really
hair-raising time trouble but he at
least uses the time that is that is
given okay Brooke c1 yeah takes yeah
it's hard to suggest anything from black
rook f8 and non c5 it just flows very
naturally f5 yeah black simply has no
active plan and this is the only thing
to think of
and now Bishop g5 as shown before this
is my white had played H form to have
this important resource covering this
risking side formation and Queenie's
have an attacking g5 which is covered
and at the end the problem is the king
it cannot escape anywhere and white is
threatening to just push in the center
after efore played d6 in fact he had was
already a more than yeah there already
was more than a good line one good line
Roxy for for example intending to
intensify on e4 also was very strong but
this seems to win anyway at Queen e5 and
now what just opens up in the center
takes J and III is the last yeah kind of
kind of desperate trying to at least get
to get a check in but yeah rook t8 can't
know the funny hoof night she a check
just kills our counter play
black has no move of course he just
needs to take it but white can just
recapture the point is that white has
read some on his own it to for example
it's not terrible because check this
just wins the house and it's always
checking check the white wine wins he
played the bishop to to e6 and yeah this
is easily doubt worth just promoting
okay just one check and everything's
covered you won discovered and black
doesn't have any checks he took I guess
probably being intern trouble and after
rook c8 artist in vodka Stein here
resigned the game
yeah very straightforward win and not
too difficult to be honest but it was a
nice strategical lesson based on the
fact that white had this had this better
development control of the default and
with 95 it was simply a case of a piece
that is so strong that you can hardly
tolerate so after the capture what has
this nice confirmation ready to form a
passport and like really am is in deep
trouble after this you know attacking
the Queen and always controlling v8 like
a couldn't secure as king and from here
I guess it's it's really lost
note that honor this using good
methodical moves to win the game and not
try to win instantly with tactics CTX b5
is such a such a possibility and
probably it is
from a purely technical point of view
the best move but his solution with
Queen g3 and h4 simply kills blacks
counterplay and this is also very very
strong I think the computer
underestimates the strength of this the
solution it gives wider a large edge but
I think what Isis is just winning here
it's no way for black to to untangle
himself
so after later ever I would see this
idea of h4 revealed and after that it
was a matter of a good technical
execution will which Anand didn't have
any problems with yeah hope you enjoyed
the game played in the Norwegian line of
the of the real opus and played by
Magnus Gardens former former coach three
years before the Challenger even was
born so it has some some funny aspect
this game in in relation to the upcoming
match I hope you enjoyed the game I'll
be back tomorrow with another game by
the Challenger thanks for watching